jusqu'à 3 heures du matin vous décidé de
rentrer avec une amie et vous n'étiez
qu'à 15 minutes de marche c'est ça de
votre domicile de décider de d'y aller à
pied vous y allez appeler vous rentrez
chez vous à pied
ça se passe où déjà ça se passe à
nanterre dacor ac l'as tu me dis qu'est
donc c'est en région parisienne vous
décidé de rentrer vous êtes avec une
amie qu'est ce qui se passe on marche
tous les dieux avec ma copine dans un
moment plein de joie on était très
contente on était toutes les deux puis
je tourne la tête et je vois de deux
hommes tout seul dans la rue normes ont
été toutes les deux avec ma copine je
perds c'est vrai c'est ça et que vous
deux c'est simplement la lumière était
orange et on était bien que ça faisait
pas peur on était vraiment bien j'ai
tourné ma tête et j'ai vu ces deux
hommes j'en ai vu un engrais en noir je
les ai vus avec tous les deux un tour de
cou autour du cou mais il n'avait pas de
manteau et je me suis dit vu le temps un
tour de cou sans manteau ce pas normal
du coup le thé regarder je vois que plus
je marche vite puis marge vite je vois
monter leur tour de cou sur leur nez
je dis à ma copine amelia amelia je
pense que c'est maintenant il va falloir
concours
du coup je me suis mise à courir j'ai
traversé la route tue plus vite que je
pouvais malheureusement j'ai trébuché et
je suis tombé les deux sont arrivés sur
moi m'ont mis au sol celui qui est avec
son survêtement noir voulait à tout pris
mon sac à main c'était son but ultime
et c'est lui qui était en gris a
commencé à moux et de coups de coups de
pieds dans tout mon corps sur ma
poitrine et surtout dans ma tête
et il n'arrêtait pas puis celui qui est
en noir lui disait arrête tu va la tuer
elle saigne trop sérieux trop tu es là
tu es c'est là qu'il faut arrêter
celui qui était en gris était dans une
folie il rigolait il prenait du plaisir
à me frapper il aimait vraiment sa fille
son coût du stress j'ai pas pu me
retenir c'est peut-être un peu la honte
mais je me suis fait dessus je n'ai pas
réussi à me contenir
et j'ai lâché mon sac celui qui est en
noir elle a pris les parties
et l'homme en gris a sorti un marteau
qui adore les bus et un marteau brise
vitre
et m'a regardé et m'a dit je vais te
finir je vais te finir
et puis il m'a roué à coups de marteau
dans la tête et puis à ce moment là je
me suis mis en pause et j'ai entendu mon
ami nathan jouer du piano j'avais une
douce mélodie au piano dans ma tête
j'entendais la tempe dire je peux pas
t'endormir maintenant je peux pas tu vas
t'en dormir tout à l'heure mais là il
faut pas que tu t'endors il faut que tu
restes là puis cette jolie mélodie de
piano s'est transformé en piano plus
batterie avec les coups de marteau et je
me faisais une musique qui me permet de
rester en vie je me remettais cette
musique dans la tête cette lumière qui
était si orange essai transformé dans le
sombre mes yeux était plein de sens je
me sentais mourir je me sentais mourir
je voyais ça que le team mes amis dans
ma tête j'ai voyez passer je voyais ma
famille
j'ai essayé de tenir du bien du mieux
que je pouvais et comment il a vu que je
commençais à perdre j'ai ouvert les yeux
et ma bouche et j'ai fait la morte
et j'aurais jamais cru pour un juge
jamais pensé qu'un jour j'aurais dû
faire la morte pour m'en sortir donc
pendant une minute les couper ma
respiration j'ai fait comme s'il était
morte après il est parti
et je pense que personne ne peut
comprendre que j'ai pris une vidéo juste
après c'est un peu bizarre mais sur le
moment je me suis dit j'ai survécu à sa
grâce à ce match a toujours
d'aujourd'hui on peut avoir la
localisation de l'endroit et l'heure et
grâce à cette vidéo je me suis dit s'ils
allaient dans mon téléphone si jamais
ils me tuent et que je cache mon
téléphone
ma famille y verra que je me suis fait
agresser ou pourra peut-être retrouver
mon corps ou sera le lieu regardez la
vidéo tu as posté juste après son
agression
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que cette vidéo
c'est pas on parle souvent des réseaux
sociaux va vous avez raison sur ce coup
là réflexe c'est un bon réflexe
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait votre ami pendant
ce temps là en fait mon ami sinon ils
n'y ont rien fait d'accord c'est me
verse 50 mètres derrière elle est restée
a été tétanisée par la peur elle
essayait à la criée mais dès qu'elle
criait il la regardait qu'elle arrêtait
crier l'acier d'appeler les pompiers la
police du bien dans le meilleur cas pour
est malade déplore de sortu est aussi
sur le coup dis donc elle a attendu et
quand ils sont partis j'ai attendu
j'attendais un petit peu je me suis dit
c'est la france devait bras à me relever
l'adrénaline a fait que j'ai plus marché
et puis là il s'est passé quelque chose
de dégueulasse c'est qu'il y avait une
voiture aux feux rouges je me suis hissé
jusqu'à cette voiture j'ai toqué à la
fenêtre s'il vous plaît monsieur aidez
moi je suis entre mourir je me suis à
baisser la fenêtre et m'a dit ce n'est
pas mon souci
il a fermé la vitre et il est parti en
roulant
ma copine m'a dit c'est pas grave marine
c'est pas grave on va trouver de l'aide
c'est pas grave c'est des cons c'est pas
grave j'ai rencontré deux hommes qui
étaient dans une propriété qui m'ont
ouvert leurs bras et mis dans leur
propriété ils ont attendu que les
pompiers et les secours arrivent et sans
ces hommes là bas je serais peut-être
pas là et je le remercierais toute ma
vie et si moi je vous c'est un grand
merci vraiment un grand merci à vous
parce que malheureusement même s'ils
n'ont pas réussi à mêler physiquement tu
es mentalement et au jour d'aujourd'hui
juste une enveloppe corporelle florian
apporte de la tristesse à chaque fois
que je marque jugé cette mélodie qui a
d'autres qui me rappelle que bien que
cette mélodie au piano qui me fait
survivre
ça m'a fait énormément de mal
la douleur physique n'était qu'obsolète
par rapport à la douleur que j'avais
dans ma tête je me suis senti sali
je me sens morte
je suis arrivé à l'hôpital avec les
urgences les pompiers les patrouilles de
police et les médecins m'ont dit c'est
quand même quelque chose dedans une vous
êtes en vie et vous ne devriez pas être
dit
m'a cassé le nez on a fait des traumas
crâniens il m'a fait énormément de mal
mais ouvert le crâne justice il ya avec
son marteau brise-vitre fins c'était
quelque chose de
très traumatisant et j'ai posté grâce à
mon amie agnès assez une vidéo sur
instagram parce que je voulais pas de
buzz naim j'aime pas du tout ça je
voulais juste que les gens voient que
même aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on n'est
pas se protéger mais c'est pas pour
autant qu'il ne faut pas sorcier parce
qu'on va pas s'empêcher de vivre pour
des gens comme ça ça sert à rien
donc j'ai posté ça pour essayer de faire
passer un message et puis même essayé
surtout de foot est égoïste mais essayer
de retrouver ces gens là bien sûr pour
qu'il paye ce qu'ils ont fait parce que
je trouve ça ignoble et puis surtout que
ces gens là se fasse pas en liberté
parce qu'eux aussi
ils sont dangereux pour diageo aussi
bien sûr
c'était c'était con cette agression ça
s'est passé à 3 heures du matin de trois
heures à 3 heures et c'était
5 dimanches matins
depuis
pouvait plus sortir de chez vous je ne
veux pas aller à carrefour je ne peux
pas aller dans la rue je ne peux même
dire si si si ceux-ci agoraphobe total
jeu dès que quelqu'un me touche je
pleure énormément je pris du temps vous
et je vais en prendre beaucoup le
pensent mais déjà le fait d'être ici ça
me re sociabilise un peu avec le monde
je pourrais pas dire que ça me fait
énormément de bien mais pardonner ça me
fait du bien
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas d'autres gens
qui vont subir ça parce que c'est
traumatisant et je pense que ça reste à
vie oui au départ c'était juste vous
pensé pour une agression pour vous
voulez votre sac c'est ça moi je pensais
juste qu'ils allaient me voler mon sac
le premier truc que j'ai protégé dans
mon sac c'était ma carte d'identité car
je voulais pas qu'ils aient mon adresse
ça me faisait très peur qui viennent
chez moi bon malheureusement ils sont ma
carte d'identité mais qu'ils viennent
ils seront bien reçus
donc dans tous les cas
maintenant c'est fait c'est faire vos
parents
vous êtes entouré par vos parents par
vous avez des frères et soeurs oui vous
êtes trois frères pour des frères ça
doit s ils doivent se dire on est cédée
grand frère s'est dit d'accord des
petits frères on pense que que quelqu'un
m'a tapé que je me suis mal défendu
c'est mieux pour eux je pense commencer
ça ça sert à rien de faire subir ça à un
enfant niveau pas encore il va avoir une
rage lait de la mère était dans un état
c'est limite si elle n'a pas acheté de
la chaux pour les brûlés c'était quelque
chose dedans une grand-mère date arrive
aux urgences elle était
comme morte à l'intérieur traumatisé
ampleur s'était tu fais ça leur a fait
beaucoup de mal aussi peut-être moins
qu'à moi mais ça les a quand même
traumatisée
qui au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai appris
que moi je ne sortirais plus ça c'est
sûr oui si tu peux aussi pour moi déjà
je n'aimais pas paris et que ça me
faisait très peur j'habite à la campagne
moi j'aime aller à la pêche j'aime aller
faire de la peinture lire des livres
j'aime vous aviez passé une bonne soirée
ce soir avant ce que vous dites c'est
incroyable c'était le pot de départ de
mon ami qui part au canada c'était un
bonheur de le retrouver après quelques
mois j'étais très heureuse et puis je me
suis dit 14 minutes c'est rien ça fait
du bien de marcher
là j'aurais dû prendre un éleveur
j'aurais dû mais si on marche avec des
sièges aurait dû on n'avance pas donc
maintenant c'est fait c'est fait et puis
faut vivre avec ça me rendra plus fort
que j'espère
aujourd'hui il vous est impossible de
marcher sans béquilles j'ai vu si c'est
ça va revenir parce que qu'est ce que
disent les médecins
c'est des hématomes à la rentrée
massoutier sur la hanche c'est juste ça
mais ça va aller niveau frac sur la par
monnet qui est cassé ça va niveau
fracture
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous êtes dans
quel esprit vous avez
vous avez envie bien sûr de retrouver
ses agresseurs ou vous dites aujourd'hui
on peut se faire agresser comme ça et on
sait que l'anc est aujourd'hui lé
n est pas très avancé ce que vous me
direz on a retrouvé aujourd'hui la
lanière de mon sac à main d'accord sauf
qu'on ne sais pas j'ai pas pu voir
j'avais les yeux pleins de manger pas pu
voir s'il avait des gants ou non mais
ils vont la faire analyser et on va
essayer de voir comment ça peut avancer
j'espère que ça avancera avec ça restera
pas seulement une main courante je suis
très triste alors elle serait très
triste on espère qu aujourd'hui votre
témoignage va faire qu'on pourra
retrouver cesser ces personnes
aujourd'hui vous avez vu quoi de ces
personnes que vous nous aidez une
personne noire une personne en gris qui
était parce qu'au départ où il n'avait
pas hésité pas j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé
la lumière et aux oranges et dans ma
tête la lumière est passé d'un bien joli
orange et un sombre rouge je suis passé
du paradis aux enfers en une fraction de
seconde et j'ai pas analysé j'ai déjà
réussi à avoir la couleur des
survêtements et sa méthode juin ça
m'étonne que j'ai réussi c'est juste
leur voix c'est juste que je vais te
finir je vais te finir à coups de
marteau qui me qui est là à chaque fois
que je ferme les yeux c'est juste ça qui
me
ment tête aujourd'hui vous arriver à
dormir a déclaré me faire ouais c'est ça
sinon c'est dès que vous fermez les yeux
vous je peux pas dormir parce que j'ai
peur de plus me réveiller
parce que je me suis vu mourir
je suis juste pas envie forcément il fut
même si je suis morte mentalement jeu
j'essaye un minimum de m'en sortir mme
c'est compliqué vous vous en sortez donc
sa thèse avait 18 ans vous êtes cette
magnifique vous êtes là on voit
extrêmement
intelligente vous avez une poésie
incroyable ce qu'on voit aussi vous
allez vous reconstruire c'est sûr mais
c'est sûr ça j'ai aucun doute là dessus
c'est sûr que la ccc des moments
compliqués
mais je pense qu'il va avoir des étapes
dès que vous soyez là aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que c'est déjà une très grosse
étape force de caractère exactement
trente force car actes et le fait que
vous puissiez déroulée comme ça le le
récit avec autant de
2,2 des tailles de haies de précision
mais vraiment de maturité c'est déjà
incroyable
et je vous dis je suis sûr que vous
allez vous en sortir parce que la
première chose tu es déjà que vous vous
en sortirez vous puissiez reprendre une
vie normale une jeune fille une fille de
la vie d'une jeune fille de 18 ans et
quand je vous entends dire je veux plus
sortir je veux plus
aujourd'hui à 18 heures ça me fait ça
doit vous faire également chez vous et
normandes peut énormément de peine
d'entendre ça on se dit rendez compte où
on en est arrivé là non c'est à dire
qu'une jeune fille de 18 ans maintenant
elle se dit je vais plus sortir dans la
rue parce qu'elles se sont sont en
insécurité
alors on sait que la police fabié
devrait certainement bien faire son
travail je pense j'espère je vous le dis
moi j'ai confiance et je pense qu'ils
vont retrouver vos agresseurs je suis je
suis je suis j'en suis certain gilles y
aura évidemment votre témoignage le
témoignage de votre ami la
vidéosurveillance aussi c'est à dire
qu'ils ont essayé de retracer le
cheminement de ces deux personnes d'où
ils sont partis où ils sont arrivés
est-ce qu'il faut dire aussi et vous
êtes là aussi pour ça c'est que si des
gens ont vu quelque chose est de près de
loin ont vu deux hommes s'enfuir est
dans le coin surtout qu'ils aillent à
apporter leurs témoignages argué taper
l'adresse c'est à nanterre c'est à
nanterre place du midi passe du midi
vous êtes étudiant temps je devais
rentrer en médecine en septembre mais
malheureusement j'ai pris une année
sabbatique pour problèmes de santé
d'accord bah elle va mettre mais des
bénéfique là pour le coup sûr je vais
bien rentabiliser et vous reprendrez
médecine j'espère en septembre l'année
prochaine